le parti socialiste les jeux y en a et
est membre très longtemps et j'ai
beaucoup d'attachement pour les
militants qui sont des gens sincères
engagé investi j'ai beaucoup d'amis je
deviens qu'elles ont bougé j'ai gardé
beaucoup d'amis je pense que dans sa
stratégie
le parti socialiste a tendance parfois à
se complaire dans la facilité de
l'opposition quand il est en gestion il
a du mal à se mettre d'accord entre la
partie je dirais plus gestionnaire et la
partie des frondeurs ont la vue et donc
pour le parti socialiste il ya une
certaine facilité à être dans la lah la
critique nationale syndical et dans
l'opposition permanente